so for you as a Dana White fan Dana  Moscow Dana must certainly go there's no  two ways about it it's Unthinkable that  he continues I think  but yet here we are with how many days  10 days 10 days in yeah since the  footage became public uh and no movement  and I think that in itself is is  interesting we talk constantly about  cancer culture and people being canceled  for all sorts of things uh and yet here  we are there is something terrible has  happened something there is hard  evidence it's happened  um and yet if you don't if you're  sufficiently powerful  and uh sufficiently able to just get  your head down and and try and batten  down the hatches then perhaps you can be  immune to cancer culture for something  which is obviously egregious